do you see that a lot people what they
want that that dream of Hollywood and
also no offense it's just you know
you're chasing something that's doesn't
mean anything
I stayed in Hollywood for one more year
and I was auditioning audition you know
auditioning and I just decided I want to
have a break to make the most in this
dunya right they want to have a great
car they want to be there one ito they
want everyone to love them they want
everyone to grab it to gravitate them to
look at how many Facebook Likes and
Instagram likes they have and who's
following them and anything that go to
that it was actually reading reading
reading the Quran come on man you ran
off he beat you so bad and you ran off
but the good story alarms to the sisters
Australian sorry it was true
how are you okay so check this out so
your your story is you're you're a
Christian and now you end up being
working as one it's like a special
forces guy right now you come across one
of the leader a Toto who was like you
know the the head guy for the Muslims
the total Ghazi and you get into and now
you're rolling around with him he's
kicking your butt is that right look
come on man you ran off he beat you so
bad and you ran off but the good story
is I'll let you finish but then later
you accepted Islam is that one part
right all right why would you disagree
how was it fighting with that thought oh
that was easy
there was a problem or two or three you
did do that right little bit but now
that wasn't a problem
did you fight - tokoto yes all right
how did that how did that go - you guys
know Turgut Oh from our Torah
I got a problem not a problem for cloud
is over it wasn't you were holding you
here you were holding your own yeah but
a tutor had you take he had you he had
you there no okay so by now you guys
know we're talking about how do you
pronounce the the series that you
started delish delish okay yeah so
real-life stories that take us from
there your your mother and father met
and then what happened from there okay
so
my mother and father met a long time ago
my father's an immigrant to Australia
from Bosnia to Australia when he was 17
years old and he traveled all over
Australia probably more than 99 percent
of Australians and he met my mother she
went she when he was about 20 she was 16
no good friends for four years they got
married they had two children my two
oldest brothers at that stage my mother
wants to take them to religious classes
and she wants to enroll them in some
sort of a Catholic sort of school and my
father disagreed strongly disagreed and
later on my mother decided okay well
let's check out other religions and
let's check out your religion and my
father came from an Islamic background
but communist Islamic background and so
he he was like a little bit unsure about
his own religion and my mother started
things in taking them to Madras oh she
loved it because she grew up in like an
affluent Catholic Society and she had so
many questions unanswered and in the
Koran she started reading she found all
the answers that she was a strict
practising came from a practicing
Catholic Christian background I would
say strict but I would say they day a
solely a solid by the wait so you're
originally from Australia I was born in
Canberra Aussie Aussie Aussie they saw
salams too
Buzz's sisters Australian Sami go
straight there so your mom now she
starts investigating so your father he's
Muslim was he practicing no I mean like
generally coming coming from Yugoslavia
it was if you had I mean if you started
practicing in Yugoslavia there's a lot
of people taken away in Yugoslavia
before practicing Islam there's a whole
list of people that were put in prison
for practicing Islam all the islands
were removed if you were caught praying
your name will go down in the list in
communism and that and so he had limited
knowledge about his Deen now my mother
when she started reading she decided she
wants to convert reverts Islam and she
spoke to my father and he pretty much
was like scared of her decision and it
took a while and she later on that and
she had conveyances name I mean she
ended up doing her research obviously if
Islam didn't provide all of the proof
and the evidence that it was indeed the
true from the Creator she probably
wouldn't have accepted she would have
stayed with what she was upon now what
would you say absolutely I think I think
the only thing that go to her that it
was actually reading reading reading the
Quran yeah if your non-muslim
you do not like this love only you just
read the Koran you see what it's about
and then this is a friend of yours Sonny
Williams Sonny Bill Williams you know he
came out recently we had that tragic
terrorist attack that happened or this
this terrorist went into a house of
worship and gunned down 50 innocent
human beings including women and
children New Zealand that's not too far
from Australia right same culture same
almost same people they're more Scottish
with more Irish English but they're the
same people same culture same end of the
world he said the same thing you should
get to know Islam and you need to
understand what the same is so it can
give that give that life which whoo
what will get rid of the button just you
know he was giving us a richer say read
the cards like get to know it's not but
just I mean if you think is it's right
try reading it just just try reading
that's what people need to do more green
read and I think what do you think of
that they're terrorists he would have
met some Muslim actually you know and
read the Koran and connected with his
mama I mean this this is the key to
removing that with that hate and that
ignorance would you agree
hey never gets anyone anywhere and I
just think it's tragic that people have
got to this stage in the world in
today's society I just think it's
appalling to to see that happen in New
Zealand to see these Facebook groups how
much people just don't know don't know
about it's not back to your mother she
was the catalyst that had you actually
now come to where you're at making
decisions because you had to make
certain decisions also were you gonna
sell your soul because you spent some
time in Hollywood is that right yes and
you offer some key roles one of those
roles is in the hit film was it
spartacus spartacus TV shows buddies
lead role the Spartacus I would you sum
the lead role six times to place
Spartacus was like one know that many
jobs always offered is this not there
was many other jobs similar to this
scenario like Spartacus where I couldn't
play the role because doing Haram things
like kissing and just telling a story
that I just don't believe roles that I
personally well yeah I mean you imagine
that look you're offered the the money
you want it's your gonna have the
stardom and this hit series was a very
hit series but now your mother because
she was influenced by the teachings the
moral teachings of the Quran of Islam
she instilled this in you and now would
this help you to make that decision you
know what my mother my mother was is the
wrong my family
the religious rocking my family when as
kids I remember her telling us when we
go home from school did you pray the one
go pray though when I was time for for
prayer was Akshar inside inside the
house when we started for prayer my
mother would say Rashad Jamal Kayla bata
called cool zone and that's almost
brother would lead and we we grew up in
a country town those at all
and just my mother's you're a convert
Islam to get us together like that can't
think of that you can't write that kind
of surface does aside in you to see when
you see a lot of people now who are
Muslim by name or their parents are
Muslim but you see is this also that we
have in lot in the States how about in
Australia where the youth and you know
they're going towards trying to imitate
that that light that Hollywood lifestyle
going more towards gangs and materialism
this all comes down to what's the
objective of life and to these people
what they eject what their objective is
so life is to make the most in this
dunya right they want to have a great
car they want to be there when ego they
want everyone to love them they want
everyone to gravitate them to look at
how many Facebook Likes and Instagram
likes they have and who's following them
and in women and things like that
helicopters and it goes on it goes on to
dunya and dunya and basically if you
want this although we'll give it to you
that's not a problem that's not hard
I'll give it to you no problem you don't
have to be a special person you don't
have to have special skills you don't
have to read thousands of books you
don't have to finish universities or
anything like that I will give it to you
if you want it
if you want the ocular that's something
else if you want the Hereafter that's
something out so the transitory world is
gonna leave you and that's amazing so
you committed now to forming that
connection with your creative five times
a day and you didn't sell your soul it
was offered the contract it was right in
front of you the money is right there
and you made a decision no I'm not gonna
sell my soul and you left all that okay
so just to talk Lucent about spartacus
spartacus was full frontal x-rated
television programs one of the first
x-rated television programs with with
the general staff and I auditioned for
six times and we went back to the photos
and I see the contract about it was they
wanted me to be full frontal nudity sex
scenes and things like that and and Oh
at that stage in my life I was I was
doing kissing on screen and full frontal
nudity I just couldn't do because my
mother has hijab and I was just like I
can't live like that my mother I can't
I'm ashamed and it was a deal breaker
and that too got broken and then later
on I stayed in Hollywood for one more
year and I was auditioning auditioning
auditioning and I just decided I want to
have a break a spiritual break and I
decided to come sorry afford to spend my
Ramadan here and when I got here from
the airport I went to the first message
that had and from their own times a day
look at that beautiful connected so many
people are trying to fate we're trying
to chase that that Mirage you know
thinking that that is where it's gonna
have me successful and happy in my
do you see that a lot people they want
that that dream of Hollywood and also no
offense it's just you know you're
chasing something that's doesn't mean
anything it really doesn't mean anything
it doesn't mean anything about you
doesn't even think about me but you're
chasing something that's material it's
all based on material it's all based on
ego and now we're here inside I believe
this is your home now so I have own
gospel oh you got married here and now
your kids your family your here this is
where you got a coffee shop go drink is
and I've never met someone I mean I'm
telling you like 99% of the people that
probably that I've had interactions with
coffee might sell coffee really don't
have an in-depth knowledge of coffee so
I call this the coffee shake right here
so what am i drinking here by the way so
people what is this pak'ma'ra
it means the bigger vein it's from a
singular state 100% Arabica single
origin we've mixed it with some butter
and we mix that's my treat I do it once
a week so you're here now you've been a
cop is about the same so tell us now
with this event because it hits so close
to home what was your reaction I mean
this is your nape neighboring country
right there New Zealand when you heard
this news of this tragic event what were
the things I went to your mind you know
one mother she is part of a community in
Australia on the Central Coast about an
hour and a half north of Sydney
and the three three years ago they
bought mustard they bought a church a
rundown church and they convert it into
a Masjid and it's located in Gosford and
they get a lot of death threats and
they've been having a lot of like
threats for the past three years about
people that are very insecure about this
Masjid opening and so I I kind of relate
with it and there's some people that
been called up my mother supported
people that did the mapping area thing
that that was coming my way or another
like I'm not surprised because there are
extremists everywhere there are extreme
Muslims there extreme Christians there
are extreme Buddhist Mara Mara
yeah extreme there's extreme people the
extreme white supremist this is
something that's just coming I mean I
just think it's up to people just sort
of handle this and the right type of
people to handle this and and for
communities to sort of come together and
just do these easy problems is a problem
society we need to expect problems and
we need to find the right solutions so
your advice is like Sonny Sonny V
Williams 20 Williams Sonny Bill Williams
Sonny Williams he came out he says I'm a
proud Muslim he's also a proud New
Zealand so I remember when we say
Muslims Muslims simply one who has
chosen to submit to the crater that
heavens on earth that's it I caught up
in all the names worshiping the Creator
not the creation and he came out and
just like you're saying you know we
believe that this is the key to
eradicating because people do things out
of feet ignorant things out of fear and
it does not appear because of all the
hype and negative propaganda people have
this false these false information about
Islam so there's some great advice what
other advice do you have go ahead I sort
of think why did this go
why did he do this for what reason but
that's I leave it there what reason for
hate is that a good thing is that better
than Islam is that better than anything
else I mean why did he do it find your
answer that and start researching
beautiful and if you're in a survival
what's the name it is your cafe we're
here from Ministry of chase Jay is a
Boston word that derived from Ottoman
Turkish which meant cave which derived
from arabic which could go everywhere to
russia to afghanistan they will have
that same word cave which means it's
very hard to explain but something like
zen mixed with enjoyment with your
friends with your food with your coffee
and inshaallah we have our team here
also jiu-jitsu club team razmik will
have you coming in so even you even be
more prepared next time when you're when
you're when you get it whether you get a
tag but now you're now you accept that
islam in the film so but mom the day
assassinated you you're gone well it was
a pleasure
very nice meeting you we could see you
again soon and I'll be back to shut off
more this wonderful coffee
thanks for couple but thank you my
brother